je suis actuellement à copenitki en
route pour Kiev après avoir visité
samedi la région de Herson nous n'avons
pas visité la capitale régionale mais
les villages autour qui ont connu des
combats très intenses ces derniers mois
et la destruction est partout les
maisons les routes les ponts et puis
aussi on voit les positions de l'armée
russe qui a occupé cette partie de la
région de Herson pendant de si long mois
mais sur place la situation est un peu
l'opposé de ce qui se passe dans la
capitale régionale où les gens
commencent à fuir parce que les
bombardements russes s'intensifient dans
les villages autour c'est la calmée et
les habitants qui avaient fui commence à
revenir pas les gens avec les familles
il semble très peu probable que les
écoles vont rouvrir bientôt mais les
personnes ayant plus de 50 ans et il se
disent que ils doivent absolument
s'entraider dans leur communauté
plus petites on a vu des retrouvailles
assez émotionnels et aussi un certain
soulagement bizarrement parce que les
gens qui avaient entendu parler de
l'intensité des combats s'attendait à
trouver leur maison complètement
détruite c'est bien sûr le cas pour
certains mais d'autres ont trouvé des
maisons que ils seront capables de
réparer ils se mettent tout de suite à
essayer d'effectuer ces réparations
avant que les températures ne baisse
encore mais pour la situation économique
dans la région c'est tout simplement
catastrophique c'est une région agricole
et les agriculteurs ont vu leur ferme
piller par les occupants russes et puis
substantiellement détruit ce qui fait
que les stocks qui restaient sont en
très grande partie détruite et on parle
ici de millions de dollars de grains
d'autres stocks agricoles et aussi bien
sûr la machine riz qui a été détruit ou
tout simplement voler par les forces
russes